- Listening skills are a
critical skill for every leader,
and you're going to learn how to improve
your listening skills today.
I'm here with my good
friend and co-author,
Dr. Julien Mirivel.
We wrote a book called
"Positive Communication
For Leaders" that this
video series is based upon.
In fact, this is the seventh
and final video in this series.
You can go back and watch
the rest of the videos.
We'll put links to the entire series
in the description below the video.
And if you'd like to sign up
for the free mini email class
that echoes everything we're talking about
in this series, you can do that as well.
And by the way, I just
wanna take a moment here
at the end of this series,
if our names sound familiar,
you may recognize us from our
blockbuster movie series, "Madagascar."
I am Alex, the Lion.
Of course, he is the original King Julien.
Now we're just joking, of course,
but our names really are very similar,
and we've had those names
before those characters.
And I actually do call Julien
the original King Julien
for fun once in a while.
And I've been called,
many times, Alex the Lion.
Anyway, back to our story.
We're going to talk about listening.
It's a key leadership behavior,
and Julien's going to
talk about this skill
from the perspective of his model
that he created on positive communication.
- When you choose to listen
as a leader, you are choosing
to transcend the perceived
differences that exist
between you and other people.
Why is listening such an important
leadership behavior, Alex?
- Well, listening is an often overlooked
and usually undervalued
communication skill.
It often doesn't look
like anything's happening,
but if you want to take
your leadership seriously,
then you have to work on your listening.
Because the higher up leaders
go in any organization,
the more time they spend listening.
In fact, as we show in our
book, executives spend twice
as much time listening compared
to the average employee.
And emerging leaders spend
more and more time listening
as they move up the ladder
in any kind of organization.
And people in all walks of life,
whether they're in an organization
or in their personal life,
love great listeners.
- But there are real
important practical benefits
to being a great listener.
Leaders who listen well and deeply
get to know their people better.
They also can be more easily identifying
the emerging problems that are
taking place on the ground.
They have more input about solutions
that could be more effective
to solve real problems.
They also are really good
if you use listening,
you can resolve the problems
before they get bigger.
And more importantly, most
of us, we want to avoid
hard conversations, difficult moments.
If you can listen a
little bit more deeply,
you can avoid these hard talks
because you're managing
problems all along the way.
For these reasons, it
doesn't surprise us that
some of the best listeners we've ever met
are leaders sitting at the top
of the organizational chart.
- So what does good listening look like,
sound like, and feel like?
Well, in our book, we use
the term deep listening
to indicate that
listening well goes beyond
superficial tactics, like fake listening,
to give people the impression
that you're listening when you're not.
For example, deep listeners
follow three key behaviors.
First, deep listeners are fully present
and completely in the moment.
Deep listeners put their phones away.
They reduce all distractions.
They literally lean their bodies in
and they listen with their
eyes, not just their ears.
Deep listeners, for
example, are never looking
over your shoulder to
see who else might be
a little more interesting in the room.
And a fully present
listener makes you feel
like you're the most important person
in the world at that moment.
They're fully present,
and that is a choice.
For example, they say that Elvis Presley
made you feel like you were
the only person that existed
in the entire universe while
he was speaking to you.
He made you feel special.
And if the king of rock
and roll had the time
to make people feel that way, so can you.
- Deep listeners are also open.
Openness is about welcoming new ideas,
perspectives, and approaches.
We know that remaining open is difficult,
but it does not mean
abandoning your point of view.
In fact, openness is all about
maintaining a really fine,
delicate balance between holding
onto your own perspective
and being profoundly open to
the perspective of others.
Openness is typically
difficult for people to develop
because it involves our ability to accept
and welcome new information,
which may even contradict
our own thinking.
We interviewed a variety of
leaders for the book that
Alex and I wrote, but
one of them said this,
"Leaders, in general, are very stubborn.
They believe in something
and they keep on pushing
whether people agree or disagree."
But he added this important
piece of information, he said,
"But I have found that listening deeply
always gives me a new perspective."
So gaining a fresh perspective,
even if one may not
fully change their view,
is obviously critical for leaders.
So as a leader, we
encourage you to remain open
to hearing new ideas,
to hearing new thoughts
and constructs that will
help you innovate, adapt,
and hopefully thrive.
- The third behavior is that
deep listeners show empathy.
Put simply, empathy is your
ability to put yourself
in the other person's shoes
to understand their world
and to feel what they are
feeling in that moment.
Empathy usually involves pitching back
what you believe you have heard
or asking a few follow-up questions
to make sure you are
understanding the other person's
point of view accurately.
So I'm gonna give you a few
straightforward examples of
how you might respond in the moment.
We're gonna be really
straightforward here.
When good listeners respond,
they keep their responses low key.
For example, they may say things like,
"I hear you," "Makes sense,"
"I see what you mean,"
or even simply, "Hm."
You'll notice that these
replies are all very short.
Great listeners are not eager
to take their own big talking turn
or to jump in with a
story to match your story.
They're entirely focused
on understanding you
and understanding your world.
As Stephen Covey might say,
"Great listeners listen to understand.
They don't listen to simply reply."
- Let's get actionable,
here is your challenge.
This is a simple action step,
but it takes commitment,
and courage on your part
to execute this challenge.
In the next 24 hours,
strive to make listening
your dominant goal in any
conversation that you're having.
It's gonna be your purpose.
Use the tips that we've
shared in this video
to listen more effectively
and more deeply.
Remember that it's a part of your job.
Here's a quick summary.
Recognize that listening is
a leadership responsibility.
And deep listening means that
you become fully present,
that you become fully open,
and that you become empathetic.
We know that listening in one-on-one
conversations is foundational.
And in our book, we also explain
how you can use the power
of listening to build
an extraordinary team
and a great organizational culture,
heart and centered on compassion.
- As mentioned, this is the seventh
of seven videos in this series on positive
communication for leaders.
Feel free to look at the entire series.
We'll put links to the whole thing
in the description below
the video, as well as links
to the book on Amazon and
that free mini email class.
And if you've watched this whole series,
I just want to encourage you
to leave a comment below.
Tell us you've watched the entire series,
and I'll be sure to heart your response
and also respond to what you have written.
And I just wanna say thank you
for hanging in there with us.
This is Alex the Lion
and the original King Julien
signing off for this series.
Until next time, thanks, God bless,
and we will see you soon.